China says it is not afraid of a trade
war with the US and it's fighting back
against President Trump with its own
tariffs on US goods this retaliation
comes after the president unveiled up to
sixty billion dollars in tariffs on some
Chinese imports yesterday that decision
sent shockwaves through stock markets
the Dow plunged more than 700 points
yesterday when Tracy's in Beijing with
China's pushback then good morning good
morning so if this does become a trade
war that last twenty four hours might be
remembered as the opening battle the
Chinese government is now saying the
u.s. is being arrogant and that it
should step back from the brink before
things get a whole lot worse now in
response to US tariffs on steel and
aluminum that went into effect today
China is now proposing its own tariffs
on more than 100 US products these
include fresh fruit nuts wine steel pipe
as well as pork and recycled aluminum
now these total about three billion
dollars those US goods would become more
expensive here in China that could cause
American farmers and companies to lose
business China's ambassador to the u.s.
went on state TV here to talk about the
possibility of a trade war as far as a
possible trade law is concerned we never
wanted to start but if somebody imposes
a trade wars we'll fight to the end
now the Ambassador also took issue with
allegations that the Chinese government
steals American technology from
companies operating here he called those
baseless and said it's a form of
discrimination John thank you Ben Ben
Tracy for us in Beijing